ah
[Música]
hola bienvenidos al debate de france 24
soy santiago lópez gonzález con el 75%
de la población según de la votación
según lo dice el consejo supremo
electoral de nicaragua el presidente
daniel ortega fue reelegido para un
cuarto mandato consecutivo los comicios
presidenciales estuvieron marcados por
la falta de propuestas de una campaña
clara y de una ola de detenciones y
también de persecución judicial a la
mayoría de los opositores en total 7 que
aspiraban a participar en estas
elecciones y se perfilaban como rivales
de ortega en las urnas también 32
líderes opositores y empresarios fueron
perseguidos al igual que los opositores
fueron acusados de conspiración y
traición a la patria según la
organización urnas abiertas la
abstención en estos comicios alcanzó el
81 5% a nivel nacional una alta cifra
que contrasta con ese 65 34 por ciento
de la participación que indica el
consejo supremo electoral una
institución que es criticada por estar
controlada por el partido oficialista
además del presidente los 4.4 millones
de nicaragüenses que estaban avalados
para votar también eligieron al
vicepresidente que en este caso fue
reelegida rosario murillo que es la
esposa de daniel ortega que también allí
pues en estos comicios se iban a elegir
a 90 diputados de la asamblea nacional y
a 20 diputados del parlamento
centroamericano el parlacen la comunidad
internacional ha tenido todo tipo de
opiniones divididas frente a este a
estos comicios en nicaragua eeuu por
ejemplo también la unión europea algunos
países de américa latina no reconocen
los resultados y han calificado este
proceso electoral de pantomima tal y
como lo dijo el ministro de exteriores
del reino de españa jose manuel alvar y
esperamos
no podemos llamarlas ni elecciones han
sido una burla lo que se ha realizado
ayer en nicaragua ha sido una burla una
burla al pueblo de nicaragua una burla a
la comunidad internacional y sobre todo
una burla a la democracia
no ha habido ni elecciones libres ni
elecciones justas ni elecciones
competidas bueno pero hay otros países
como por ejemplo rusia y venezuela que
han respaldado las garantías de este
proceso electoral incluso aplaudieron la
transparencia y el triunfo por cuarta
vez consecutiva del presidente daniel
ortega y de su esposa esposa rosario
murillo veamos
estuvo prohibido organizar
las elecciones se realizaron de manera
ordenada en pleno cumplimiento de la
legislación nicaragüense según tengo
entendido la casa blanca literalmente
anoche cuando se terminaron las
elecciones se negó a reconocerlas y
pidió a todos los demás países que
hicieran lo mismo consideramos es
inaceptable y condenamos enérgicamente
esta posición realmente hubo un proceso
democrático en nicaragua ortega partió
con algún tipo de ventaja ante el
anuncio de más sanciones internacionales
cómo va a afectar esto a este país
centroamericano qué significan estas
elecciones para la izquierda
latinoamericana y para las democracias
de la región cuál es el mensaje que se
está enviando desde managua porque
ortega intenta perpetuarse en el poder
repitiendo la historia de la dictadura
de la familia somoza contra la que él
mismo luchó por muchos años ahora el
mandatario está estrangulando las
libertades y también los valores
democráticos y la división de poderes
hay en nicaragua el análisis de las
elecciones presidenciales en este país
centroamericano es nuestro tema de
debate hoy en france 24 y para
analizarlo hemos invitado a xóchitl
ocampo ella es abogada ex diputada por
el partido frente sandinista
de liberación liberación nacional' ella
se encuentra en la ciudad de managua la
capital nicaragüense también está con
nosotros israel lewites él es activista
político nicaragüense actualmente está
en el exilio se encuentra en ciudad de
panamá y aquí en el estudio de france 24
está con nosotros jasmine balaguer e
internacionalista politóloga y también
directora del centro de pensamiento
estratégico ustedes también nuestros
televidentes también pueden participar
dejen sus preguntas sus comentarios todo
tipo de ideas que ustedes quieran
compartir con nosotros a través de las
redes sociales estamos en facebook
también en instagram también estamos en
twitter síganos como france24
arroba santi logo que es mi cuenta
personal les recuerdo el numeral es
numeral el debate efe 24 esperamos sus
comentarios me informan del departamento
de internet que hay una encuesta en
línea para que ustedes respondan y dejen
allí sus comentarios en torno a la
pregunta que les estamos haciendo a
quienes visitan nuestras redes sociales
pues tenemos a los invitados tenemos el
contexto y tenemos el tema por supuesto
comienzo con özil en la ciudad de
managua preguntándole por sus
impresiones
en torno al desarrollo de estos comicios
presidenciales que no permitieron el
ingreso de la prensa extranjera tampoco
la llegada de observadores
internacionales independientes y pues ya
hacíamos un poco el contexto unos
minutos atrás cuáles son sus impresiones
qué tal muy buenas noches saludos
gracias nuevamente por la invitación
para nosotros de juego los nicaragüenses
estamos celebrando la victoria la
soberanía ha sido ratificada en esta
votación masiva del pueblo nicaragüense
que asistió
increíblemente muy emocionada porque
participó la familia nicaragüense
estamos hablando de los jóvenes y los
adultos mayores mucha presencia
inclusive de las personas con
discapacidad que nos reflejan que están
votando por la esperanza por el amor por
esa soberanía que tanto le ha costado
sangre a este pueblo nicaragüense y que
tanto significa para nosotros para la
dignidad del pueblo nicaragüense de tal
manera que desde ayer que se celebró
cívicamente este proceso electoral que
el pueblo ha hecho la historia porque es
bueno informarle que dentro de lo
que ha registrado el consejo supremo
electoral
sobresale la lista de los botadores
pasivos chis y más gente en otros
procesos electorales no había votado
sencillamente porque no querían o porque
estaban alguna situación que no les
américa a votar esta vez y lo hicieron
de tal manera que el padrón pasivo tuvo
un gran significado muchos jóvenes se
animaron a salir a votar muchos
abuelitos abuelitas chile de manera que
esto ha sido una fiesta cívica de gran
importancia histórica para el pueblo
nicaragua israel en la ciudad de panamá
no muy lejos de allí de nicaragua
cuéntenos cuáles son sus impresiones de
este proceso electoral
ha sido una completa farsa una burla y
una tragedia para nicaragua estamos
viendo cómo se consuma un modelo
autocrático en donde una familia
simplemente ha privatizado el estado
nicaragüense no existe ninguna división
de poderes y por medio de la serie de
leyes expolia de un tridente de leyes
con los cuales han criminalizado
cualquier ejercicio crítico y de pronto
veces secuestro de cualquier oponente
político que según las encuestas no lo
digo yo hubiera superado enero ortega en
unos comicios medianamente transparentes
lo que vivimos fuera de ortega
compitiendo contra sí mismo un altísimo
nivel de abstención que supera el 80 por
ciento definitivamente en lo que es
popularidad el frente sandinista y el
dictador tea vive en su momento más bajo
según una encuesta se haga un 9 por
ciento sin embargo se sostiene por la
fuerza de las armas de la represión de
la intimidación
vertido a nicaragua en una enorme cárcel
en donde nadie puede alzar la voz o
recibe las pruebas represalias y yo
quiero hacer un llamado por la
liberación de los presos políticos ya
hay casi dos centenares de presos
políticos ahorita secuestrados en las
cárceles de la dictadura de amigo ortega
y aquí en el estudio france24 jasmine
sus impresiones opinión sobre este
proceso electoral gracias a santiago la
invitación como era de esperarse una
instrumentalización del concepto de
elecciones que utilizan personajes
populistas dictadores autoritarios como
es el caso de daniel ortega en donde se
se instrumentaliza para tratar de dar
una legitimidad en su elección ganando
en esta vez la cuarta oportunidad con
casi el 75 por ciento la misma que la
encuesta gallup hace un mes dijo que la
población quería que ya no detentará más
el poder daniel ortega los mismos que
decían que votarían por cualquiera de
los candidatos que están presos en este
momento todas esas características que
ha demostrado daniel ortega desde que
está en el poder
evidencia que ya no estamos en una queja
de nicaragua ya no está en una
democracia esta es prácticamente una
recto gracia en donde se caracteriza por
el nepotismo en donde los miembros de su
familia ocupan cargos estratégicos como
es la vicepresidencia
la policía y todo esto va a llevar
nicaragua a que se enquisten que se
enquiste como es el caso de cuba o de
venezuela en donde lamentablemente la
presión internacional como se ha
manifestado
en todos estos años no va a ser efectiva
y por el contrario va va a tener el la
estrategia por parte de ortega para
seguir ahí
özil haciendo un barrido por algunos
medios nicaragüenses que registraron los
hechos de ayer algunos mostraban en vivo
en las calles de managua con poca
afluencia de personas en las calles e
incluso en los puntos de votación había
pocas personas
concentradas al aire entrevistaban
algunos nicaragüenses y ellos mismos
decían que estaban acostumbrados a tener
que hacer largas filas y esperar para
poder votar y que en esta oportunidad no
era así precisamente porque había muy
pocas personas fue muy baja la
participación entonces allí de acuerdo a
lo que se registra lo que dicen las
imágenes que bueno las imágenes no
mienten
le decía al inicio que las familias
nicaragüenses se deportaron en la
participación a las urnas a depositar su
voto pero hay que ver qué medios son los
que ustedes monitorean y además el señor
levy te está desde panamá y le invita
listas de colon que obviamente no están
aquí para observar el proceso pero si
estuvieron más de 260 representaciones
las dos opciones no pudimos monitorear
el proceso porque el gobierno ortega no
dejó entrar a la prensa internacional el
equipo de periodistas de france 24 no
puede entrar a nicaragua y la prensa
internacional le tocó registrar los
hechos desde costa rica eso es un
proceso con garantías
no puede registrar la gente fuera de las
fronteras
un bastante de presencia de medios
internacionales 4 el lema es que cuando
varios varios medios de comunicación
inclusive ya lo hacían usted en sus
notas vinieron desde renuncia de eeuu y
es importante mencionar ahora que lo
dice y vinieron observadores de eeuu les
bloquearon sus cuentas en facebook le
dijeron que estaban suspendidos tres
días precisamente porque estaban
tratando el proceso entonces eso
dificulta que la verdad pueda salir al
extranjero
que dios no permiten que se dé a conocer
la realidad acá en nicaragua ahora yo
quisiera aclararles algo el señor le
eviten decía más del 80 por ciento de
atención de dónde sacan esa cifra dice
que la hizo una supuesta encuestadora
esas son cifras totalmente falsas pero
además si quisieran mentir deberían
tener una mentira creíble que dijera por
lo menos el 50 por ciento pero quién va
a creer que hay una obtención de más del
80 por ciento o sea eso es hasta querer
buscar la inteligencia humana porque
hubo una participación masiva de la
población se habla de que un 75 por
ciento en la intención del voto
diferente sandinista como ya lo decían
las impuestas de mieres que se dieron a
conocer
y no la que mencionabas invitada
colombiana es otra marca encontrada
encuestadoras que definitivamente no es
afín al gobierno y que por el contrario
hacen la oposición pero no puede ser
afín a un gobierno es que eso es el
primer punto de partida una encuestadora
no puede ser afín a un gobierno y a una
candidatura precisamente tiene que ser
independiente para que garantice la
velocidad de los resultados ahí ya
habría unos primeros indicios para
pensar que definitivamente las cifras
están siendo manipuladas por parte del
gobierno vamos a ciudad de panamá israel
su opinión sobre estas imágenes que se
veían de las calles de la baja
participación esta diferencia en las
cifras y que no hay presencia de la
prensa internacional allí incluso no
llegaron la cantidad de observadores que
debían haber llegado porque hay un
cambio en la ley electoral que nicaragua
no los nombres como unos observadores
sino como unos acompañantes dándole otro
tipo de categoría
lo que estamos viendo en nicaragua es
un dictador siguiendo el manual del
dictador creando una realidad paralela
por medio de un sistema de propaganda en
donde repiten a un estilo goebbeliano
una serie de mentiras para construir una
supuesta realidad obviamente este
discurso es insostenible porque si no
solamente era un gran dado apertura a la
prensa internacional de absolutamente
cualquier tendencia y hubieran ustedes
podido confirmar con sus propios ojos
que era lo que estaba ocurriendo
obviamente el país prefiere cerrarse y
crear un cerco informativo en donde
solamente prevalezca un discurso oficial
esto no es novedad y esa sumamente
preocupante no solamente porque este
ejemplo la tragedia sola te para indicar
para todas las ciudadanía de la región
yo diría del mundo porque el hecho de
que un dictador criminal como ale ortega
logre a salirse con la suya y continúe
impune a pesar de los crímenes de lesa
es una llamada de atención para todos
los ciudadanos porque no podemos
permitir que en pleno siglo 21 continúa
este tipo de ejercicio criminal del
poder que finalmente está en contra de
todos los derechos humanos
jasmine aquí en el estudio de france 24
usted lo mencionaba y retomo algo de lo
que dice israel esto es un mensaje claro
para la región y para las democracias de
la región y también para la izquierda de
la región latinoamericana cuál es el
mensaje que se está mandando desde
managua con este tipo de acciones y con
este proceso electoral que hay unas
características que comparten todos
estos tipos de
dictadores o populistas
como como chávez como correa como ortega
que cuando llegan al poder lo primero
que hacen es cambiar la constitución
para perpetuarse como lo hizo a atacar a
los medios de comunicación en este caso
de ortega poner a familiares
bueno la prensa pero también allí hay
algo que
bueno el sistema internacional no cree
en las estadísticas de nicaragua y esto
le pasa a haití y le pasa a venezuela en
donde
todas estas características es un
ejemplo por ejemplo para para colombia
porque manejan el mismo discurso de la
persecución de la división entre buenos
y malos entre ricos y pobres perseguir
la banca y demonizar en nicaragua casi
el 80% son católicos y el discurso que
hace este señor ortega es el de tratar
de demonios a los opositores ese mismo
discurso lo vemos en
dirigentes como gustavo petro también y
esto es una clara señal porque los
estados no pueden depender de el
altruismo de los gobernantes sino de las
instituciones y de la fortaleza de ellas
y esto es lamentablemente lo que no hay
ni cara hoy en estos países en donde
reina populismo claro soy y le pregunto
ahora por los
participantes de estos comicios por los
candidatos que estaban allí postulándose
para la presidencia
y como siete candidatos fueron enviados
a la cárcel están en este momento
detenidos sin haber tenido un proceso
judicial un proceso que va muy lento sin
haber recibido una condena unos cargos
simplemente se les detuvo se puede decir
de de manera arbitraria como ve usted
ese proceso que justo unos meses antes
de las elecciones los candidatos de la
oposición todos terminaron detenidos o
exiliados
cuando recordemos que hay que hacer
imparciales siempre desde que se habla
de un medio de complicación y eso es
base fundamental para que a la hora que
los inviten a un país se sepa porque si
está parcializado porque obviamente
nadie lo va a querer invitar pero si
quisiera aclarar desde el punto de vista
de que dice 7 cantidad atún yo les decía
inclusive la entrevista anterior de qué
partido son igual le pregunto al señor
levita dirigente analista de dónde sacan
esos títulos que quien lo ha dicho
tienen ha dicho que son líderes que me
diga el señor le evite de qué partido
político gay y me diga de qué partido
político eran esos candidatos hay que
dejar claro aquí que el calendario
electoral en las fechas en cuyo se dijo
que había una fecha tope para las
alianzas para la unión de personas con
estos a los que usted diría lo que es
obviamente que están de parte de estas
personas que están encarceladas le
llaman candidatos ni siquiera llegaron a
ser precandidatos por decir algo porque
no tienen q partido político yo les
decía que cuando alguien va a una
contienda debe tener un partido político
y una casilla lo cual ninguno de estos
señores lo tiene ellos lo que están
presentándose ante un proceso penal
judicial precisamente porque lo que sí
han sido son vendepatrias y hay que
decirlo por su nombre porque han sido
financiados por gobiernos extranjeros
para inestabilidad económica social en
nuestro país de tal manera que no
podemos llamarle candidato cuando el
papel de ellos ha sido meramente
golpista en este país ni en 2018 vimos
su protagonismo y su liderazgo e ir a
promover tranque de la muerte en su
liderazgo a desfinanciar delincuente
para que para que desestabilicen el país
pero en ningún momento podemos llamarles
líderes políticos inclusive al señor
levitas que me diga de dónde salió su
liderazgo para mí el líder nace del o
carlos nace de conocer las necesidades
del pueblo y ellos lo que vemos que
comandante daniel ortega hombre que
recorrió el país entero que ha tenido
apertura con todos los sectores sociales
pero aquí quieren ganarle candidato a
señores que han tenido esos buenos
apellidos que han sido beneficiados con
gobiernos anteriores inclusive
han sido corruptos de los gobiernos
anteriores del nuevo liberalismo y a eso
le llaman líderes y le llaman cantidad
pero no sí pero pero a la luz
a la luz de la constitución y la ley
todos los ciudadanos son iguales y ellos
no han tenido un proceso judicial no han
tenido un juicio no se les han imputado
cargos oficialmente son procesos que no
van
con el procedimiento normal entonces ahí
es donde uno empieza a tener dudas sobre
este tipo de detenciones porque los
procedimientos no han sido tal como lo
pide la ley nicaragüense
ustedes ya lo vea así pero si le
pregunta un nicaragüense más bien
indignante ver con qué corona en esta
otra está esta gente siempre siendo
financiada y hasta ahora por fin se les
está procesando porque desde el 2018
inclusive es el indulto a una buena
cantidad que habían sido estaban
involucrados con el intento del golpe de
estado y ahí andan libre se les dijo no
repetición ahora vemos que se les
anunció e inclusive el comandante les
dijo todo tiene su límite y estas
personas continuado si querían
nuevamente perpetrar un golpe de estado
y recibiendo guión desde eeuu donde
están las pruebas de esos millones eso
sí porque no sale solamente américa
porque el gobierno de ortega no muestra
es una justicia nicaragüense no lo
demuestra
precisamente se ha levantado a sentirlo
bancarlo a este tema de las personas que
estén involucradas
eso se puede esconder y precisamente son
pruebas inclusive de todo el lavado de
dinero que ha hecho esta persona ahora
porque dice la constitución política
solamente me permite terminar esto
porque hablar de nuestra constitución
política significa respetar al pueblo
nicaragüense dice su artículo 2 la
soberanía nacional reside en el pueblo y
la ejerce a través de instrumento
democrático decidiendo y participando
libremente en la construcción y
perfeccionamiento del sistema económico
político social de la nación soy súper
soberano lo ejerce el pueblo por medio
de sus representantes libremente
elegidos de tal manera que siempre
nosotros exigimos que sea que haya un
respeto por la soberanía propio y que no
se usen ser socio inclusive a veces lo
consideramos como injerencia y estás
queriendo opinar sobre la realidad del
país es totalmente distinta a la que
centraba israel sus impresiones sobre el
manejo que tuvo la oposición en estos en
este proceso electoral de 7 personas
detenidas por unas acusaciones son los
procesos que no avanzan y que pues no lo
que los están acusando o por lo menos la
comunidad internacional que las ha
pedido no las ha visto
es evidente que han y ortega sabe que no
cuenta con la base popular para
enfrentar los comicios medianamente
transparentes
en un momento aún con el control total
de todas las instituciones el consejo
supremo electoral sabía que ni así
podría
vencer a cualquier candidato opositor
medianamente creíble y era simplemente
asombroso ver como cada precandidato que
daba el paso al frente y que decía yo
estoy interesado en enfrentar a daniel
ortega y ese precandidato parecía tener
una simpatía y un apoyo inmediatamente
aparecían cargos en contra de esta
persona y llegaba a ser secuestrada en
horas de la noche por la guardia daniel
ortega de una manera absolutamente
ilegal en horas que no son sin cargos el
tiempo de detención que antes era de 48
horas que si todavía algún tipo de
acusación formal
la persona libre lo subieron a tres
meses así de cuarenta y ocho a tres
meses puede darse la libertad de
secuestrar a alguien el gobierno debiera
ortega para investigarlo y es la fecha y
estas personas que están siendo
torturadas en la cárcel que han perdido
algunos se habla de que han perdido más
de 30 libras que estás vendiendo
lentamente asesinados estas personas
hubieran podido derrotar aniorte a en
comicios medianamente transparentes y de
norte a lo sabía por eso procedió a este
atroz acto del secuestro
yasmina en el estudio de france 24 en
varios países como eeuu también la unión
europea han rechazado los resultados de
estos comicios y ya anunciaron que van a
imponer una serie de sanciones en el
contexto en el que esta nicaragua en
este momento estas sanciones como la va
a afectar va a aislar a daniel ortega
completamente el escenario internacional
pero ya hemos visto que las sanciones
internacionales es muy poco lo que
pueden afectar a los gobiernos que es lo
que quieren hacer finalmente los países
al imponer las sí claro parecería antes
una ventaja y lo podría usar como
estrategia pero realmente cuando ya está
en el nivel de la situación en la que
están nicaragua como la que estado
venezuela o cuba al igual que las
dictaduras del norte de áfrica estos
países árabes la presión internacional
simplemente no es no es solamente no es
efectiva sino que es como como lo dije
una estrategia interna aquí tampoco
interesa la imagen internacional ni el
debido proceso de los detenidos
simplemente se detienen porque son
opositores y este tipo de liderazgos
populistas o dictatoriales autoritarios
son son vistos como unos mesías que
tienen las respuestas a todo y son
considerados ellos el bien y el resto
los opositores son considerados el mal
aquí lo vemos como daniel ortega los
trata de demonios y esto es una
narrativa que lo va a mantener y va va a
estar en un nivel mucho más mucho más
arriba que es muy peligroso para ya
cometer algún tipo ya de genocidios o de
desapariciones
porque no podemos confiar en todas las
estadísticas que muestran nicaragua como
las de los demás países y es lamentable
porque ni la presión internacional puede
hacer algo y el destino final como ha
sido de estos dictadores mencionados es
terminar como bien ortega que se parece
mucho somos a terminar igualmente con un
atentado o heredar el poder a su esposa
que sería muchísimo peor de lo que es él
o heredar lo a algunos de sus familiares
en los cargos importantes que tienen el
estado y hacer esa misma herencia de
poder como ha sido en común
israel en ciudad de panamá hablemos de
la ciudadanía nicaragüense que tuvo que
enfrentarse a estos comicios ir a votar
en un escenario político muy particular
ya lo hemos dicho acá cómo está la
polarización allí en nicaragua y cómo
está daniel ortega dentro de los
nicaragüenses gozó de mucha popularidad
en años anteriores en sus mandatos
anteriores el país tuvo un repunte
económico en algunas áreas pero ahora la
situación es muy diferente como están
los nicaragüenses hoy en día
comprendo un poco de la historia dónde
proviene de ortega recordemos que él
surge junto con la revolución sandinista
en los años 80 después de derrocar la
dictadura de somoza después él pierde
las elecciones en 1990 contra violeta
barrios de chamorro
empieza a ejercer la oposición una
oposición destructiva diría yo
saboteando en gran medida a los tres
períodos democráticos que con sus luces
y sombras
estuvieron antes de que en el 2007
regresará nuevamente
daniel ortega al poder y nos hoy ha
regresado una abrumadora mayoría
simplemente logró el mínimo un 37 por
ciento para ganar en primera vuelta
porque los pulsiones estaban divididas
desde entonces él inicia este proceso de
afianzar su dictadura no pensemos que
fue el 2018 ahorita que ayer ella empezó
con su práctica autocráticas fue desde
el día que por medio su control de las
instituciones que en gran medida nunca
lo perdió récord de suprema logró torcer
muchas cosas siempre a su favor claro y
bueno hoy lo que tenemos es una sociedad
absolutamente
polarizada en donde la gran mayoría lo
que pudo hacer durante estos comicios de
farsa fue simplemente abstenerse y
mantenerse al margen porque decía mi
candidato está preso mientras tanto a mí
ortega tiene una base violenta muy
pequeña pero armada dispuesta a matar en
aras de conservar su status quo o si
usted como ciudadana nicaragüense como
conocedora de la historia de su país
ferviente defensora de su nación de su
país a usted no le parece que ortega
está volviendo a repetir capítulos
anteriores de la historia nicaragüense
de la dictadura de somoza con represión
persecución exilio de políticos y medios
de comunicación y sobre todo
perpetuándose en el poder cuando uno de
los fundamentos de la democracia es
precisamente la alternancia del poder
como lo ve usted
para los nicaragüenses que conocemos la
historia e inclusive para quienes
vinieron a estos tiempos estamos claros
que hacemos total absurdo considerar eso
porque la dictadura somocista que le
costó más de 50 mil vidas humanas a este
pueblo no liberarse incluso era un
títere del imperio el dictador somoza
obviamente sabemos que un absurdo
totalmente lo que pueden decir ni
siquiera compararlo con somoza pero
nosotros buscaremos en la provocación
sencillamente porque nuestros tiempos
han cambiado y nosotros estamos felices
celebrando una victoria en la que el
pueblo ha dicho que aquí y nicaragua se
respeta afuera pueden decir lo que
quieran pero aquí dentro nosotros
estamos haciendo patria y estamos
defendiendo con toda dignidad nuestra
soberanía nuestro amor estamos
defendiendo la paz esa para es tan
bendita que nos mantiene a los
nicaragüenses trabajando a diario
estamos defendiendo todos esos proyectos
sociales las escuelas los hospitales lo
que los los que no tienen ver esos que
critican en nicaragua y que dicen
defender la libertad lo que no quieren
ver es ese progreso que hay en nicaragua
las mejores carreteras el siglo sólo lo
importante que es la participación de
las mujeres los tiempos más del 50 por
ciento de funcionarias públicas la
juventud presente en fin eso no lo
quieren ver allá en el extranjero sólo
quieren ver lo que ha vendido para los
hijos de la patria que son un porcentaje
pequeño y que el que está metido el
señor levitas porque todavía sigo
esperando que me diga a qué partido
pertenece él o quien me ha dicho que es
un dirigente político porque yo hasta
ahora lo conozco y sepa no participe en
ningún partido político pero no si
quiero dejarte claro quisiera dejarle
claro que yo creo que lo que han hecho
los vendepatria de cajade inclusive a
quienes lo han patrocinado a quienes le
han financiado porque le han dicho
tantas mentiras allá que se la creyeron
en el extranjero pero que nuestro chino
ha aterrizado a la realidad en nicaragua
y escucho ya es que se me acaba el
tiempo para finalizar el programa pues
precisamente para hacer balance por eso
usted está invitada en este programa
desde managua para contar la perspectiva
suya desde allí nosotros no estamos
vendiendo aquí una publicidad de nada ni
haciéndole el favor a nadie ni vendiendo
un lado de la historia estamos tratando
de poner esto las dos caras de la moneda
creo que eso es pertinente decirlo me
quedan ya pocos minutos 23 minutos para
terminar el programa quiero hacer las
conclusiones comienzo entonces
con israel- en ciudad de panamá
preguntándole qué va a pasar en estos
cinco años de mandato de ortega de lo
que viene ahora para este nuevo mandato
presidencial rápidamente por favor muy
puntual
se aproxima una etapa muy dura para
nicaragua ortega no es un presidente
legítimo muchos países están concuerdan
en que estos comicios fueron una farsa
un fraude una pantomima y esto va a
tener serias consecuencias económicas
pero tenemos que encontrar la manera de
castigar económicamente y de hacer
inviable este proyecto autocrático de
ortega porque muchos de esos círculos de
hierro están haciendo mucho dinero con
este sistema y de alguna u otra manera
hay que asfixiar a este círculo de
hierro para que no siga lucrando con la
tragedia el pueblo nicaragüense si soy
el su opinión de lo que viene para estos
cinco años de gobierno ortega
quisiera mencionar rápidamente dos cosas
porque bueno usted tiene los invitados
allá que están en contra mi posición
entonces mediar el doble tiempo mi
verdad para poder contestarles a ambos
pero si quisiera dejarle claro al señor
le evite cuando él dice que
inmediatamente los candidatos eran
encarcelados cuando manifestaban su
intención de participar eso empezó en
julio porque porque definitivamente se
ha demostrado que estamos recibiendo el
financiamiento y estaban llamando además
a direcciones y sanciones en contra de
su propio pueblo la ley prohíbe esas
conductas apátridas entonces eso fue en
julio quiere decir que sus candidatos
eran candidatos a partir de julio cuando
el proceso electoral era en noviembre
las elecciones en cantidad surge a dos o
tres meses de unas elecciones es
totalmente absurdo eso lo que refleja es
lo que hemos venido diciendo que ellos
nunca fueron candidatos y que jamás
serán preparados porque ni siquiera
entienden partidos políticos para poder
inscribirse y correr como candidato otra
cosa que quisiera aclarar rápidamente
porque mediado pocos segundos
y es que el señor levitt es un auto
exiliado pero precisamente por eso
último que he dicho yo le quiero decir
que por ese tipo de declaraciones si él
estuviera y nicaragua sencillamente si
iría detenido porque los nicaragüenses
no podemos tolerar que estén llamando de
la forma más descarada a que no agredan
con sanciones a nuestros pueblos porque
agreden a nuestros pueblos y están
pidiendo sanciones en contra de nuestra
nación por eso es importante aclararle y
con esas conductas con las que él ha
tenido aquí les aclaramos por ese tipo
de declaraciones patrias y están
detenidos muchos y esos sean rápidamente
nuevas sanciones contra el nuestro
pueblo y también aquí en el estudio de
france 24 conclusión quedan 30 secuelas
por llevar decía que lo más peligroso
para un gobernante es estar en el poder
mucho tiempo porque se acostumbra a
gobernar y los gobernados se acostumbran
a que ese es parte del paisaje y
lamentablemente en nicaragua esto
seguirá sucediendo no habrán reformas
económicas que benefician a la sociedad
habrá más concentración del poder y más
represión contra el pueblo contra el
pueblo nicaragüense que esperamos tenga
la fortaleza la sabiduría para que pueda
enfrentar esta situación pues si tienen
ustedes las dos caras de la moneda en
torno a este tema mis invitados les
agradezco haber estado con nosotros a
ustedes por la sintonía sigan con
nosotros
[Música]